you know we said earlier that the
Negredo often occurs at the beginning of
the work and it was commonly understood
that the work progressed in these three
phases the Negredo the albedo and the
roubideaux and I want to read just a
little bit from Jung about it where he
talks about how the Negredo becomes the
albedo because I think that's kind of
where we are right now in the
conversation he says if the work is
difficult and strewn with obstacles the
alchemical opus is dangerous right at
the beginning you meet the dragon the
cathodic spirit the devil or as the
alchemists called it the blackness the
Negredo and this encounter produces
suffering in the language of the
alchemists matter suffers until the
Negredo disappears when the dawn will be
announced by the Peacocks tail and a new
day will break and that's the albedo so
it is the suffering that turns the
blackness into the whiteness I would add
that it's the conscious suffering of
that that makes it alchemical versus
instinctive perhaps that we know what
we're struggling up against and so when
we first begin to feel uncomfortable and
aware that something is churning but we
don't know what it is
Jung referred to that as the emergence
of the Massa confusa which is a word I
throw around all the time
you like saying that don't you Jason it
rolls off the tongue tripping away and
it just knows it's a big confusing mess
you know and if we think about it as a
big roiling cloud with all kinds of
images just halfway poking out of it and
all kinds of feeling and lightning bolts
you know singing around it
that we come into this inner state where
we're boiling but we can't quite put our
finger on the problem yet I think all of
us can associate and remember moments at
least where we felt that way and if we
can stay attentive to it and not go back
to sleep
things begin to emerge which we normally
don't like to see in ourselves but which
can by the way be very valuable and then
we're on the path of change if we can
put our hands on it and not let it go
your rights are very movingly about
being in this place of the Massa
confused and the Negredo and he went out
in the morning and and sat by the edge
of the lake and Zurich and built little
houses and so on he was lost and he said
that he needed your support a point of
support in this world and that his
family and professional work were that
to me and I think I want to offer that
up as that there is also that in the
Massa confusa and in the suffering what
do you have what needs to be done you
need to go out and get some groceries
is there a meal to be prepared is there
a phone call to be made I said a room to
be cleaned there's always a room to be
clean and he says his family and
profession always remained a joyful
reality and a guarantee that I also
ahead a normal existence well what is
the next step what is the next thing to
be done what can you put your hands on
or put your voice to that you could do
right now in a a the advice given is
just to do the next right thing which I
really love that it's very practical
when you're lost you're confused you're
depressed you're you don't know which
end is up what is the next right thing
to do even if it's just you know in the
bathroom getting the bathroom yeah but
it's lovely it's lovely and it's
rounding and I think we have lots of
examples of that you feel what you feel
and what is the next right thing that
you can actually do I think that the
image you're bringing forward Deb for me
rightly belongs to the albedo stage and
particularly one of the images of doing
the laundry I feel like in the
conversation we keep slipping out of the
Negredo into the next stage because
sitting in the Negredo is hard even in
our conversation to Jerse circumambulate
around this particular emergence of what
we don't want to see unnecessarily how
will cope with it not necessarily what
comes next but just in the discomfort of
what we're seeing mm-hmm that that
actually is transformative and if we
solve it too quickly I tend to become
suspicious and we can go into a
cleverness a clever solution so that we
don't have to feel uncomfortable and
lots of therapies will do that very
quickly
oh well dual thought in the searching so
don't think about that anymore
choose three thoughts that actually are
comforting and relaxing and every time
you have the uncomfortable thought just
go to the comfortable fought and just
shut that down you know I mean there's a
lot of advice around that and the reason
we like that advice is that we don't
like being uncomfortable and nothing at
us wants to suffer so sitting in the
Negredo is feeling that we cannot escape
the reality that's emerging and that we
must sit and brood on it and look at it
and not go away to something else and
the question that that I would ask is
what am I being brought down to I mean I
think one aspect of the Negredo is that
it feels and it does feel inescapable
you may want to escape it but often you
just really can't you know it punctures
your defenses and I like your question
Joseph what am I being brought down to
it there is a humility
that goes along with it often we have to
admit that we thought we had it all
figured out and guess what we actually
don't and I think that that is true on
an individual level it's also true on a
collective level we we did not think we
could be laid low like this I don't
think the global economy could just be
cut off at the knees just by a virus I
think that's so importantly so I think
about just several months ago this great
debate in the United States between
whether or not we should put more energy
into the welfare state and by that I
mean the social safety network should we
fund universal health care should we
strengthen Social Security or Medicare
Medicaid you know all of the safety nets
of our culture and that was met often
with a kind of bravado that one would
never need that if you plan correctly
you should never be dependent upon some
kind of an agency or anything that is
governmental that we're all kind of you
know pioneers in the 1800s
and what's happening now with this
sudden emergence of shadow and one of
the pieces of shadow is dependency that
there is this enormous feeling of
vulnerability in the American psyche and
dependency and then this crying out for
a kind of parental caretaking response
from the government that was vilified
just several months ago even gleefully
vilified so this goes to your comment
Lisa of the humbling that's required in
this case to admit dependency and
vulnerability yeah and of course this
relates also to this idea of the
relative ization of the ego and Edward
Ettinger a union analyst who wrote a
great book actually on alchemy it's
called
anatomy of the psyche alchemical
symbolism in psychotherapy
he talks about this concept a little bit
in relation to the mortification and the
Negredo around King Lear he early in the
play he is kind of so sure of himself
and so sure of his own authority and
over the course of the of the drama
there's he loses authority power and
control and then of course he loses his
dear daughter and he undergoes this
total mortification and of course goes
mad but it's in this Negredo that he is
transformed because he gets a glimpse of
the transpersonal psyche that he is now
willing to serve and I'm sort of sort of
been paraphrasing Edinger there but I
think that's a lovely example and and
perhaps Joseph you'll accuse me of
slipping into the albedo you know kind
of wearing where it goes but I think you
know it is always going somewhere -
exactly
that's what I have been thinking about
is how important it is to think about
where this might take us and just to
begin to even imagine it of where where
is the Telos where is the trajectory as